Cristina lambridge hizo el anuncio en un
sencillo mensaje en su página de
Facebook la ministra de defensa alemana
ha presentado su dimensión a Olaf shots
el hecho de que los medios de
comunicación se hayan centrado en mí
durante meses ya no permite informar y
debatir objetivamente sobre los soldados
la bundesbear y la dirección de la
política de seguridad en interés de los
ciudadanos alemanes
la posición del hambridge se había
vuelto insostenible desde su
nombramiento en el Ministerio de defensa
ha cometido numerosos errores garrafales
en febrero del año pasado fue criticada
por kiev tras anunciar el envío de 5000
cascos cuando bolodim selenski pidió
armamento pesado también utilizó un
helicóptero el ejército para irse de
vacaciones con su hijo a principios de
enero el video en el que presenta sus
deseos entre dos fuegos artificiales
también fue juzgado inapropiado sin
embargo Jones agradeció la labor del
hambre durante su gestión
la ministra de defensa me informó que ya
no desea continuar en su cargo he
trabajado bien y con mucho gusto con
Christine lamberts durante muchos muchos
años y ahora durante la terrible guerra
de Rusia contra Ucrania demostró un
tremendo compromiso para garantizar que
Alemania avance después de décadas de
estancamiento para realizar los cambios
necesarios en las defensas de nuestro
país pero también para el apoyo a
Ucrania
las repetidas equivocaciones de la
ministra la convirtieron en la figura
política menos apreciada y en la
Encarnación de las deficiencias del
ejército alemán cuyo equipamiento está
anticuado su dimisión se produce en un
momento en el que Berlín se encuentra de
nuevo bajo presión para entregar tanques
a Ucrania el viernes está previsto un
cónclave de aliados occidentales en
torno a Estados Unidos en la base de
Rammstein una reunión en la que deberían
anunciarse nuevas ayudas a